[Music]
I think something that's really crazy
about stand up is
there are stand-ups with like 2 000
followers on Instagram that are
unironically insanely good Riders and
they're [__] hysterical and
uh that's just what they are and no one
knows I think there's a crazy band of
that or like spectrum of that in comedy
where there are dudes that are just so
insanely good and they just never get
the recognition one dude who I'm
actually super happy for is starting to
pop off a little bit everyone's seen his
Clips I think it's Jeffrey asmus can you
look him up I'm not falling for that
nasmus not fall no I I think I'm [__]
up his last name pronunciation like
whenever a guy brags about having a 10
inch [__] I'm just like whatever dude I
got 10 4-inch [__]
actually
we had to go to church a couple times
yeah kid and my daddy always told me son
the only goal in life go to church get
to heaven that's the only goal in life
is to get to heaven because we all know
there's a reward in heaven right and the
reward is that your hot cousin ain't
your cousin no more
why do you like this joke it's because
you're from an ugly family that's not
that's not my fault if you're from a hot
family like mine on the count of three
let's shout out that sexy little someone
you guys okay a one a two a three Lizzy
that's not her name my mom made me
change it for this
because Lizzie's married now and your
little joke is ruining Thanksgiving
[Laughter]
yeah man damn that was great oh he's an
aceman Lizzy yeah
if I look at a dude like this and I
think it's easy watch something like
this you're like [__] I can't but this
dude is on stage all the time grinding
it and I think it's like rather than
it's easy because I think the phone puts
us in our heads but you gotta you know
contextualize these people and yeah
you know one day I hope to be that funny
you know yeah you just feels like you
gotta do the clip thing
yeah that's why I've been begrudgingly
doing it I'm about to post one about uh
yeah I'm about to do the hard swap one
from Houston cash but unabridged
full Raw
unabridged I I have directors a cut yeah
I did a I removed a dark moment hmm
but uh
you're bringing it back in going all out
nice balls to the wall I'm just counting
down until I go back into to doing stand
up well this weekend right when's your
show it's on Friday
dates dates Friday
that's it come see me in Montreal no I
mean
after that I gotta get back on the horse
commit
sucks man all the
all good stand-up feels like it's in New
York
it's not feel like it's here yeah
La feels pretty dead really for stand up
yeah it feels like it's on life support
just no one here or Austin
yeah Austin's crazy
um it's another spot just go you know
rub shoulders with the comedy Mothership
guys yeah yo
I'm here I'm here to rub shoulders yeah
what's up I'm here to network boys
so you're excited for this hike yeah I
am I'm very excited are you actually
yeah I mean it's like I love being
outdoors and it is one of the most
beautiful hikes
like it's known as is that it's like
waterfalls and what's the what's the
temp supposed to be like it's not bad
because most of it is above 10 000 feet
so like when it starts apparently
there's like a heat wave there right now
so when it starts it's gonna be like
blisteringly hot but then you know the
higher you go the cooler it'll get did
you get around that if you start early
uh yeah maybe
I don't know I'm just like they're along
for the ride just there to Vibe yeah
but I did I got a bunch of like airplane
or like air
what's the astronaut food like yeah you
got MREs or you got like no no it's just
like Pace Burgers no it's like bags of
like beef cheddar pasta but it's like
dehydrated and you just oh yeah yeah
[Music]
oh bro you should uh before you go you
should pick up
a mountain meal
I think that's what it is yeah those are
good those are is it like the silver uh
packages silver blue yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what I have I have a bunch of
those what'd you get I don't know I
didn't look at it oh just got a bunch of
some of them are boo-boo really yeah you
should text me later what your flavors
are like yeah this is exactly what I got
wait when have you eaten these on tour I
used to eat these at the comedy club on
tour really yeah because some of those
towns there's just nothing after nine so
what's the best one then
I think for keeping okay
I think the fettuccine alfredo is
probably the best in terms of
something that tastes decent and then
just sits and you feel like you have
like a lot of carbs and energy to last
they got a lot of other ones that are
supposed to be like spicy
they don't really hit the rice meals are
kind of suss the rice based ones
so I would say the more Italian the
salmon sashimi is a little weird yeah
yeah yeah
it's weird that they send you the fish
and they're like it's living but you
have to kill it I don't know why you
have to do that part that part's strange
yeah
the black bear the baby black bear
chunks are like pretty good yeah that's
pretty good
[Laughter]
oh my God catching one of these and like
like rotisserie
your family comes back
all right we're just at the river like
showering off I was like I got dinner
it's on this on the stove oh my God what
is that that little guy yeah the little
guy off the tree yeah is that little
demon
man yeah
got rid of his uh I'd shoot that one
that one looks oh come on that's the
cutest one so far oh man that looks like
someone I know you ever seen a sun bear
imagine walking around like uh abandoned
the trail and seeing this okay
that's what I'm saying yeah right there
you imagine seeing that oh
what the hell was it look at that thing
it looks like a giant dog yeah yeah that
one that one yeah that one that's the
best nope that's the best maximize that
MF what the [__] would you do you came
around the corner and saw this start
praying
I feel like you'd be like like a moment
that's like usually in a a24 film or
something
where I just stared it long enough and
it looks at me
and I just started hearing
yeah yeah
the bottom half looks like a Planet
Fitness locker room
hahaha just an old dude hunched over the
bench staring at his nuts yeah the whole
thing kind of looks like that yeah it's
just yeah it's just that actually yeah
this could just be that some guy
crawling to his locker yeah they just
hung over the bench he's like can you
throw me that towel